the jurogan experience do you have any
regrets that you didn't start fighting
like when you were young i wish i well
look it's funny because like i started
playing football before all that
concussion [ __ ] came out but all you
heard about was like boxers with
you know head injuries or head trauma
cte and [ __ ] before it was called cte
um so i always wanted i always favored
individual sports over team sports i
[ __ ] hated team sports i only started
playing football because my older
brother played football and then i
realized that girls like football
players
and then i realized oh i'm kind of good
at football so [ __ ] all right
but i asked my mom was like can i box
and she was like
no because you're going to [ __ ] get
brain damage and you're going to ruin
your face and i paid money for your
braces and your teeth now you're gonna
[ __ ] your face up
and then i was like all right but then
meanwhile you know she'd let me go run
full speed
into another human being who's also
running full speed you know with like a
piece of plastic on my head like when i
first probably started playing i was
like uh seven years old and then
it's like one size fits all my shoulder
pads [ __ ] came out to here and my
helmet was [ __ ]
wobbling around so it like
you know definitely wasn't like the
1950s but it ain't like it is now right
you know so the only time i've ever been
like knocked unconscious is playing
football
which is a pretty scary [ __ ]
uh experience because you lose time
the first time i did it we were doing a
drill i was like 12 years old
two guys 10 yards apart there's a cone
off to the side in the middle and you
literally run full speed and smash each
other that's the drill that's the drill
it's like an angle attack on the drill
one guy's on offense the running back
everybody else is on defense
and so they say go you got sprint five
yards boom at an angle and you know
car collision
but did i hit this kid and i [ __ ] got
up i was woozy
got to the back of line and just boom
you know it's kind of like little giants
you wake up everybody's around you you
[ __ ] it's like oh it's okay dude he
does that to everybody
i was like [ __ ] y'all let me go with him
dude i [ __ ] you don't like me man
and then uh when i was in college
um i ran i was running down on uh
kickoff are you familiar with football
yeah so i run it down on a kickoff and
at the time you can't even do this
anymore but they'd put like the offense
and defensive lineman and the wedge and
the dude with the ball would just they
was just like [ __ ] clear house
so i just like [ __ ] it and just close my
eyes and dove in there oh and like my
net and it was like on the far sideline
my next cognitive memory is like i'm
walking around on our sideline i'm like
dude how the [ __ ] did i get here i was
just over there now i'm here wow and
then like five minutes later all right
kickoff team go again i was like dude i
don't i don't know if i should
but you know at the time it's like you
can't be a [ __ ] dudes [ __ ] go
and now they're like oh dude now they
stop people from doing [ __ ] like yeah
they're like
if you get ko now in a football game do
they just stop if you if they even
suspect you of having a concussion they
take your helmet
and you're down
back and there's you know when i played
like [ __ ] like that was encouraged
oh he doesn't want to play anymore
[ __ ]
[ __ ] he's like actually you know that
guy's actually you know a little bit
smarter than the rest of us
isn't it crazy that it's so recent that
they've figured all this out yeah
and well i think
i think the big turning point there was
a guy named uh
junior seau who was a linebacker for uh
the chargers committed to his committed
suicide and they you know
they don't know if you have cte until
after you die and they study your brain
and they're like
his brain's not right you know and uh so
then that after that i think is when
they started you know changing the rules
and
stuff because you know football has its
play today it doesn't really look like
how it was like the big hits was
encouraged blindsides were encouraged
he's like oh [ __ ] dude you saw what i
just did to that guy if i can you know
laugh about it
all right now you get kicked out of the
game and you have to set out the
following game as well
really so they're trying to figure out a
way to make the craziest most non-safe
sport ever safe well i was like you know
so like i think a lot of people like
ignorant back then but now you know
like the risk that you're taking so yeah
sign the waiver and go sign the waiver
and also you know it's a opportunity for
greatness yeah that's the thing it's
like you will take that risk but if you
become a superstar the rewards are
pretty substantial i mean if you're a
superstar in the nfl and you can you can
bang out five six years like you make us
get that money financial amount of money
like if i knew then what i knew now
would i still play football absolutely
there's nothing you could have done to
stop me from from playing outside of an
injury like yeah dude i [ __ ] i loved
football i like everything that came
with football i loved the lifestyle of
football
and you know at the time i thought i was
going to make a lot of money playing
football
so
you know yeah i'll take the risk and
you know same thing with fighting like
oh you're worried about your brain i
mean
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there you seem fine now yeah well you
know you know i think mushrooms help nad
helps yeah
i guess that's like preventative stuff
so